hey youtubers is Charlie happy Doctor
Who week so in honor of the 50th
anniversary me and a bunch of my friends
are doing special Doctor Who videos
every day through Saturday so today I'll
be doing my top 5 Doctor Who villains of
all time be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll also have info in the
description starting with number 5 the
doctor himself so I know this might be
cheating just a little bit but I always
consider the greatest heroes to be their
own worst enemies River Song even said
during series 6 that the doctor is one
of the most feared men in the universe
and during the 50th anniversary we're
going to meet the warrior dr. John Hurt
number 4 the master so Sherlock Holmes
would not be the world's greatest
detective without Moriarty and the
master is the doctor's Moriarty the
master has done everything from mass
genocide two things resulting in the
death of more than one doctor and
possesses his own measure of
regeneration the Time Lords even granted
him a new regeneration cycle in exchange
for his help during the five doctors
everybody who wants Johnston to come
back in series eight or series nine
raise their hand
number three the Time Lords so I know
this is another controversial choice but
the Time Lords are one of the most
destructive forces in the universe next
to the Daleks president Rassilon even
claims that Time Lords created black
holes which are the most naturally
destructive force in the universe
president Rassilon even went on to try
and end time itself so that the Time
Lords could have sent to a higher state
of being and on the other side of the
time war number two the Daleks one of
the only other Doctor Who villains to
possess the ability to time travel the
Daleks are one of the most fearsome
Doctor Who villains just because they're
so willing to alter their own biology to
achieve perfection and unlike the
Cybermen they're completely willing to
kill members of their own race that they
deemed to be imperfect they also possess
a high degree of freewill making them
really unpredictable and now my all-time
favorite Doctor Who villain the weeping
angels unlike a lot of other Doctor Who
villains you can't even close your eyes
around them have you ever tried to not
blink for more than a couple minutes it
is agony you can't even poke your own
eyes out because then you wouldn't be
able to look at them you could totally
make the argument that angel Bob and
Statue of Liberty angel are just a
little bit silly but I think they're
totally within the tone of Matt Smith's
more physically comedic doctor so it's
impossible to do a top five list without
leaving so many amazing Doctor Who
villains off the list be sure to write
your top 5 in the comments below me and
my friends are also doing a special live
stream with BBC America on Saturday that
starts at 2:30 p.m. I'll be sure to add
a link in the description as soon as we
post it right now check out some of the
awesome videos that my friends are doing
on their channels by clicking on one of
these annotations thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives